i don't be liking how a lot of these
blogs they be trying to set me up like
it's like i'm so tired
of being like social media punching bag
because seriously like it's like
i'm in a place that it's like i can't
mentally take it like it becomes tough
for me cardi b making a passionate plea
telling her fans that getting dragged
online is taking an emotional toll on
her i feel like people have thrown so
many things so many different crazy
obstacles the rapper went live on
instagram to vent about the hate she
receives on social media and blogs cardi
buttons be getting really pushed
and i really hate it
because are we trying to be nice like
you know i have my publicists and people
they'll be like cardi you need to chill
carter you needed this you needed that
but it's like
i just hate the really weird sick [ __ ]
bro like
so where did this all stem from well
when cardi b appeared on angela yi's lip
service podcast she reacted to the
backlash she got when rolling stone
named her album invasion of privacy one
of the 20 best hip hop albums of all
time i understand that people feel a
certain type of way but don't try to
disrespect me or my work or my album
because your mother was your mother was
listening to my [ __ ] but that wasn't the
whole clip just a snippet that went
viral i don't be liking how a lot of
these blogs they be trying to set me up
like it's like i'm so tired
of being like social media punching bag
i am really tired of it like and like
you know sometimes
i feel like because i'm very expressive
like i express myself too much or
because i'm ghetto a lot of people like
to guess like me
and say that i'm crazy but i'm not crazy
and as a result the rapper says it's
changed to how she uses social media now
that's why i'm don't go as live as much
as i go used to
and that's why i get like i have like a
phobia like
like people was like cardi you have to
do interviews you gotta think but it's
like that's why i'd be scared because
it's like i'm just i'm just tired of
being a punching bag and it's like
i don't want to be like a sensitive
person like i used to like and just go
crying and going like angry but it's
like it's a lie and now she's asking for
them to leave her alone for the sake of
her mental health it's like seriously if
that's like your end goal for me to get
dragged like
just stop because seriously like it's
like
i'm in a place that it's like i can't
mentally take it like
it it becomes tough for me you know like
i am a i'm a tough person
but it's just like it gets too hard
when every single day you become social
media punching bag
and then people do things like to
provoke it even more bacardi dealing
with the challenges of fame is nothing
new juaniti spoke to her in 2019 she
shared how her life's changed since
becoming a star it's definitely harder
like the more money the more problems
the more people um
that
that things they know you and their
opinions it just gets harder people
don't understand some people don't
understand the the struggle some people
don't understand the work that i put in
so they will just always try to think
that it came easy for me but she's got a
place to channel all that negative
energy oh i got a whole lot of [ __ ] to
talk about there's a lot of things that
i don't be saying that it's like you
know what every single time that i say
it people eat me up for a live from it
they say i complained so much so you
know what i'm just gonna put it in my
music then yeah like honor hit single
press
press press press
and the track she collabed on with her
hubby offset clout
people need to hear this it's a lot of
names on my headless